hi this is charles hoskinson chief
executive officer of input output
and i've decided to make a video
explaining what is bitcoin
and what is the point of the blockchain
industry
this video is inspired by uh jk
rowling's recent tweet where she asked
for the industry to explain to her
why should we care about bitcoin what's
the point of it what's the purpose of it
is it real is it not real uh so that was
her call to action
and i've answered that call to action
and i've decided to make a video
all right so let's talk a little bit
about
the 64 000 question what is bitcoin
i started in this industry in
late 2010 early 2011 uh as an investor
and a minor
uh and then uh professionally i quit
everything else i was doing in life in
2013
and actually entered the space as a
full-time vocation
so i've been in the cryptocurrency space
now for about seven years
and i founded many projects in the space
but i started with bitcoin and i started
with something called the bitcoin
education project
and the goal there was to try to bring
as many people as possible into our
ecosystem
and to also dispel a lot of the common
myths uh
fear uncertainty disinformation and
misnomers and things that have been
cropping up
and in 2013 there's certainly a lot of
them and unfortunately today there's
even more
the reality is despite the fact that
bitcoin is pervasive with
millions of people in our ecosystem and
uh mainstream knowledge of it very few
people actually understand what bitcoin
actually
is its point where it came from why it
was created
and where this industry is going why we
exist what's the
relationship for example between bitcoin
and blockchain
this is something that not many people
in the mainstream public understand
so the purpose of this video is to start
from first principles and kind of work
our way up
to what is bitcoin and then explore a
little bit about what the blockchain
industry is as a whole
and why it's such an exciting industry
and why i've chosen to spend seven years
of my life in this industry and my hope
is that
many other of the leaders in my industry
can also make explainer videos
to explain why they entered and what
they feel is so special about the things
that they do
as well as giving a shot at defining
bitcoin
so let's start from the very beginning
in 2009
bitcoin was created and bitcoin was
created
uh by an unknown person or persons
referred to as satoshi nakamoto
basically this was a pseudonym
and the creator remained anonymous in
fact the anonymity of the creator is
so strong that even after the email
account that the creator used was
compromised
and the emails revealed to the general
public no one has
since been able in the 11 years to
discern who satoshi nakamoto actually is
so true to form bitcoin has always had a
bit of mystery from
the very beginning but really what the
point of bitcoin was
was to be an experiment
and basically it's an experiment with
frustration and passion
so the passion component
the passion component of bitcoin
was really about an exploration of what
is money
and can we create better money
it's important to understand the context
of where bitcoin came from if we look at
2009
this was right on the back of the 2008
financial crisis
which was the worst financial crisis for
the world since the great depression
and as a consequence people were
starting to go back to first principles
and ask fundamental questions of
well are our central banks creating good
money what makes good money
can we create better money does money
need to be controlled by centralized
power
do we need banks or can you be your own
bank
what is the influence of the internet on
money these types of questions
and so if we deconstruct money much the
same way that satoshi nakamoto did
and the people in our industry did we
could look at a
a very nice economic definition that's
existed in pretty much every 101
textbook
and we see that there are three
properties that money has
one it's a unit of account
two it's a means of exchange
and then three it's a store of value
it's kind of a funny thing that most of
us spend
at least 40 hours a week working making
money
we have jobs we chase it a lot of people
dream of becoming millionaires
but then when you try to actually
deconstruct what are those silly pieces
of paper that are in your pocket what
are those numbers in your bank ledger
when you log into your
chase app or your wells fargo app or
whatever it might be
you get your atm receipt nobody really
seems to think too much about
what are these things what do they mean
why do we use them
so let's explore this a little bit
and then hopefully we can kind of build
our way up to where bitcoin came from
the
passion side of things and then we can
perhaps learn a little bit more
about the frustration side of things
so first off a unit of account what does
that mean
well it's so ingrained into our culture
now that we tend to miss this
but what if we didn't actually have the
ability to
measure prices in a dollar or euro or a
pound sterling
so what if instead of saying well my
services will be 30
or instead of saying that that couch is
300
we had a non-standard unit of account so
every time you went to a different store
they'd actually charge different prices
for different things like
oh i need some 45 packs of green tea for
this and that over there
i'd like a 50 pound bag of sand
it would be pretty chaotic and it would
actually be difficult to have price
discovery you would never really know
if something was expensive or cheap
everything would be relative and
it would almost be like a barter system
so the point of a unit of account
is this concept of standardization this
gives you a sense of understanding
how expensive things are how cheap
things are
relative to some standard that you
underst
that you know that you are familiar with
you have a relative sense
of whether a million dollars is a lot of
money or a little bit of money
relative to the things that you can buy
and trade with it and
other properties means of exchange
is just that you have two or more
parties they want to conduct commercial
activity with each other
they have something whether it be a
product or service that you want
and you're trying to acquire it from
them so basically money is that
middleman that allows you to efficiently
exchange that value with your
counterparty
and then finally a store of value is
this concept that
when you get this money it doesn't
magically deteriorate doesn't disappear
so as soon as you put it in your pocket
it
evaporates in 24 hours or something like
that or spoils or rots
for example could you imagine using food
as money
you might be able to standardize it you
might be able to actually use it for
commerce and people certainly value it
but food does tend to rot over time
especially things like fruit or other
commodities like that so store values
this concept of the durability
of value over a period of time and does
it hold it does it lose it
so these are the three fundamental
properties that
anything that aspires to be money must
have
and every sovereign currency whether it
be the u.s dollar
or the yen or some other currency
has these properties at least
arguably has these properties and for
the most part they allow
a sustainable stable economy deform
then there are kind of level two stuff
so these are those are the fundamental
things
so you can say level one the most
foundational principles
and these are things that go into the
quality
so the quality side of things are things
like is it easy to move and transport
it's kind of a silly concept but imagine
gold as money well if you had gold as
money very heavy
it's very difficult to move around it's
difficult to store
i it invites certainly people
trying to rob you these types of things
so the
transportability of money is super
important especially when you talk about
large transactions across borders could
you imagine a
system where people had to pay in gold
for things that were occurring
across the sea so for example a purchase
from the united states
to the european union let's say germany
and you had to mail the gold to the
person and wait for it to arrive
so transport is you know certainly a
hugely important component
durability is another
good money should be somewhat durable
for example
let's see if paper money but that paper
money is poorly printed
and over time it tends to wear down very
quickly to the extent that the bills are
actually
destroyed you consider that not to be a
very good money
or what if your money rots or has other
properties that make it deteriorate
quickly
so we'd like money to be durable and
this is why
most monetary systems started with
coinage
building things from metal in fact metal
is so durable
i personally have coins that were issued
during the roman empire
they're still around so it gives you a
sense that you can have high durability
over a long period of time
there's also things like fungibility
this is probably one of those terms that
you've never heard before
or you can't remember the definition of
it but it's a pretty simple idea
basically you cannot distinguish or you
don't really care
to distinguish between two units of the
currency
so if i have a coin and you have a coin
and they both say a dollar on them
you don't particularly care or hold one
in higher esteem
this is not true for all things there
there's certainly cases like for example
coinage that's been improperly minted
and it's a collector's item
or perhaps maybe your coin belonged to
somebody special
but in general fungibility is an
extremely important component
of money because you don't want the
money itself to get in the way of
commerce
the means of exchange unit of account
you want each unit to be identical
from the other units and this is
certainly true with digital monies
the digital dollar that lives on paypal
is indistinguishable from the digital
dollar that lives in your jpmorgan chase
account or something like that
okay so we have the ability to transport
the durability of the asset the
fungibility
and can you divide it
so divisibility is a very important
property as well
imagine going to a swap meet or a garage
sale and you only have a 20
bill and the person at the garage sale
doesn't have change
how would you actually conduct commerce
and you want to buy something that's 11
so you have to kind of figure this out
and so divisibility is one of those
things of
can we break it into sufficiently small
pieces
so that we can get very specific about
the pricing of
items so certain currencies
enable this quite well especially
digital currencies
other currencies you're at the mercy of
both parties
of you know how do you break this down
and in fact
some currencies are losing some
divisibility there's been many
discussions throughout the years for
example
getting rid of the penny which is a
fundamental unit of account
so these are some of the properties that
go into the quality
of money the ability to transport it the
durability the fungibility of it the
divisibility of it
and then you can even go even further
and you can talk about
concepts like inflation
deflation
you can talk about concepts like credit
and debt
and they're all interconnected with each
other and
ideas about supply
so even
today despite the fact that it's 2020
there
are still some definitional issues when
you look at these things
about uh what is actually the true
definition of inflation or deflation
there's an austrian definition a
classical economic definition
and then credit and debt are kind of
interesting concepts unto themselves
so as you go up levels you kind of start
with some fundamental ideas and
properties
of unit of account means of exchange and
store value
and then you say well there's some
things that we'd like our money to have
to be high quality and then if we have
high quality money that has great
properties
then we have to kind of look at the
long-term viability of it and we have to
look at
our confidence and its ability to
sustain an actual economy
for all of modern economies to run you
actually need
credit and debt and for all modern
economies to run you need to be able to
understand the value of money over time
or else people will not have faith and
confidence in it so
this is basic monetary policy 101
and what satoshi did with his experiment
of passion was say okay i'm going to
take
a very particular set of opinions
about all of these things and
this overall goal of these opinions
is decentralization
that's the key word and decentralization
from the perspective of
when we actually try to make these
systems work in practice
so let's say we have alice
and we have bob and alice and bob
actually want to do commerce with each
other they want to actually trade in
exchange with each other
when they actually want to do that they
have to usually do it through some form
of middleman
okay and generally speaking many
middlemen so let's say that bob runs a
coffee shop and alice is buying coffee
and she uses a visa or a mastercard to
purchase that coffee
there's actually multiple middlemen
multiple networks multiple protocols
that stand between alice and bob before
final settlement occurs
so even though alice has a quick and
easy payment experience
to actually get that value over to bob
is a very complex heavily regulated very
expensive
and not super inclusive process in fact
that process is so not inclusive about 3
billion people throughout the world
lack sufficient financial access to have
real economic identity and so we tend to
term them as
unbacked the concept of decentralization
is saying can alice and bob have the
same kind of relationship that they
would have
with cash
but do this over the internet
and this is a major major major question
because with cash you'll notice
something it does not require
a central authority it does not require
middlemen
you can just simply directly hand
somebody a 20
bill you can directly hand somebody a
bag full of quarters
and then purchase something with that
and they hand you the product or service
okay now that money does
have some sort of meta data behind it
has some sort of infrastructure behind
it like nobody would just accept a piece
of paper
it has to say something like a federal
reserve note or issued by the bank
of england and so you trust the
credibility of that so there's really
two steps to this process
one is how do you build an online money
that doesn't require
central authority
okay no central authority and online and
how do you get people to actually have
faith in this currency
and these are two completely different
things it's one thing to construct a
transaction system where alice can do
business with bob
it's another thing entirely to construct
a transaction system
where bob when he receives that unit
that you've created that bitcoin or
whatever you want to call it that
digital token
actually believes it's worth something
it's worth his time it's worth its
products and services
so this was in essence the experiment
of bitcoin can we create an online
currency can we create some sort of
online unit of account some sort of
online proto money if you will that has
a lot of really cool properties about it
that replicates the utility and function
of cash
but does not require a central issuer a
central bank
like the federal reserve or the bank of
england
yet still people would accept it for
products and services
bob would actually want to use that
money this was a hell of an experiment
to conduct
it required the invention of a lot of
really unique technology
for example proof of work and blockchain
and very clever
application of cryptography but at its
core
it was an experiment of passion and
frustration the passion was
can we create this new type of money
that
follows the concept of decentralization
it allows alice
and bob to have a direct relationship
with each other
we get rid of any central authority it's
online by default
and somehow it's built in a way that
people have enough faith in it
that it's going to be around it's going
to work it can't be hacked
and it doesn't require a central
authority to give it credibility
the frustration component was that the
money systems that we have today
are now working so well for us
historically all fiat currencies tend to
eventually
deteriorate and collapse because of the
political and moral temptations to
debase them for short-term gains at the
expense of long-term gains
for example the countries of venezuela
argentina
zimbabwe the warmark republic in germany
there are many cases of hyperinflation
there was one in hungary
throughout the years and many people are
a bit concerned about the
massive monetary expansions we've seen
over the last 15 years in particular
as a direct consequence of the 2008
financial crisis and the most recent
the covid funding that's occurred 6
trillion dollars perhaps now 9 trillion
in the united states and certainly more
throughout the rest of the world
so the frustration was saying can we
remove people from this process
so that we can have a bit more objective
predictability
and the objective predictability is
basically saying that
we know the supply ahead of time and we
know by which rules the supply is going
to change
so we understand this monetary policy we
understand that there's not going to be
dramatic changes to the qualitative
aspects of the system
we understand what the terms and
conditions are up front
there's no there's no hidden end user
license agreement there's no bureaucrat
that can wake up on the wrong side of
the bed on tuesday
and then suddenly say we're going to
massively increase the supply or we're
going to do it to help me win an
election or something like that
so that was the frustration component
and certainly many of us live in that
in that world so that in essence is
where bitcoin began
it began in 2009 there's kind of this
idea of money
and it said hey let's have some passion
about it
and that passion is going to have a
philosophy behind it of
decentralize everything we can and by
decentralization we mean that people
can individually do business with each
other without any middlemen
required and they can do that natively
online
no central authorities required for
those transactions to work
and they're going to have so much faith
in it that the system will be
self-sustaining
so sustainable
and also valuable
those two properties sustainable and
valuable
and the beautiful thing is that since
2009
to 2020 mission accomplished
not only has bitcoin grown from a very
small network that was unstable and
unsustainable
uh it has grown to a point where it has
become a global scale network worth
over a hundred billion dollars and you
can literally buy pretty much
anything you want and get any service
you want using a bitcoin
uh it's a truly extraordinary experiment
from that particular perspective
and uh we all in this industry
are frankly in awe of just the
durability
the resilience and the remarkable growth
of the underlying technology there are
very few examples in human history where
something has gone from a small group of
people
to over millions and millions of users
in every country in the world
and had such a pervasive impact on law
and regulation
and innovation of an industry as bitcoin
it's actually outpaced the growth of the
internet
by a large factor so mission
accomplished definitely as an experiment
now the heart of bitcoin
what makes bitcoin work is really this
idea of a blockchain
so the problem is that if you're going
to create a digital token
you have to have a ledger somewhere
and that ledger is basically
just kind of a database
and it's a very special kind of database
it stores history
so it's a database of facts
stores history and what type of history
does it store
it stores transactions
so ordinarily when you have alice and
bob
and they want to do business with each
other online
they're going to use an intermediary
like paypal or something like that
and there's a lot of things that go into
this transaction before it even happens
alice has to prove that she actually has
that money she claims
that she wants to pay bob with and there
has to be some sort of address
some sort of way of sending that value
to bob okay
so the whole point of middlemen like
paypal
or other payment processors money
service businesses
is to basically act as a proxy to sort
all that stuff out
but the minute that you get rid of them
you remove them from this process you're
kind of left with this issue of
well how does alice prove that she has
the money that she claims and how does
she actually send it
to bob and then how does bob know
when he's actually received it when it's
actually in his account
it can't be taken back from him these
types of things
so where does bob go and who does he
trust and that was a tremendously
difficult problem
and this is the core innovation of
bitcoin was to build a system
in 2009 uh basically a blockchain
to solve this problem so succinctly a
blockchain is just simply a ledger
and it stores transactions
and those transactions allow you to
verify
anyone to verify bob or anyone else
claims such as i have this many units of
bitcoin uh so i have two bitcoin
for example if i say that bob can
actually check that
this is a property called inclusive
accountability
basically we can all check each other's
homework
we can all see the record so
what happens is that there's this
database in the sky in the cloud
and bob can look at it and if
alice is trying to send a transaction to
him uh he's actually
able to say yes
that's actually to bitcoin it exists
there you go and then he's able to
confirm
that when she initiated that transaction
the network itself
received it processed it
and he actually has it
so how that's done it uses something
called cryptography
it uses a mechanism of consensus called
proof of work
and a litany of other complex things and
they're beyond the scope of this
introductory lecture but basically
math and computer science is used
to create some sort of database in the
sky
the ledger and we call that database a
blockchain
because once a record has been written
it's a fact
just like george washington was
president you can never change that
no matter how much you'd want to or or
desire to
it's just something that happened it's a
record of history so
it's a very particular type of
blockchain of database that is immutable
meaning you cannot change records inside
of it and because it has this property
called inclusive accountability
it means that anyone in the world can
actually verify that these transactions
and these records
happen if you assert you have something
and you try to spend it
everybody in the world who has this
protocol can run it
check it and that math and crypto
actually allows you to verify that it's
right
this was a revolutionary concept because
every attempt to do this
previously required some trusted third
party
to maintain the ledger bitcoin was the
first example of something that was
released
that did not require a trusted third
party the network by its very mere
operation
would be able to simulate that and of
course the minute
that you create something very
innovative and revolutionary
it inspires people to dream and say hang
on a second here
the world is just not financial
transactions this leads us to the second
part of the lecture the blockchain
industry
they say hang on a second here there are
all kinds of things in the world
that we are trusting third parties to do
that we really would not want to for
example voting
i would love every time i vote
to be able to verify that my vote first
was
counted in second that my vote was
accurately counted
so i'd love to be able to know that i
when i have the right to vote it's been
properly recorded and my vote has been
recorded
and know that for fact for every other
person
i don't want to trust a third party to
go count those votes for me i don't want
to trust a third party
to handle that system for me because
it's a vector of attack
and if we're making life and death
decisions and deciding who gets to be
president and
how the economy is going to run we have
to have a lot of confidence and faith
in voting so voting is another example
of a system
that you could do differently property
is another example of a system you could
do differently
so currently property is managed by some
form of registry
so if you have a title or you have land
somebody has to keep that database
but what happens if somebody can
manipulate or edit that database or what
happens if the government changes like
when isis took over syria
then they can go and just decide to
change history
and then it becomes very difficult after
things uh get back to normal to decide
who actually owned what where
what was the versions of history and in
many cases because it's too expensive to
maintain these systems
millions of people throughout the world
live on undeeded land
what about different types of financial
products
so bitcoin was focused on
money and it was focused on what is good
money
and it's still a big debate of whether
bitcoin is good money or not
it's a good debate of what is money in
general but it was very clearly trying
to be one thing but we have other things
like
for example microsoft stock debt
instruments like bonds
representations of things for example
tokens representing gold or
a commodity like oil so are there
different ways that we can
represent these using the same systems
that bitcoin uses to represent a bitcoin
and not require trusted third parties to
manage these systems and the answer is
yes
so a lot of people are looking at that
supply chains are another great example
of this
so in supply chains for example right
now we have a pandemic
what about global supply chains for
personal protective equipment or
vaccines or medicine
you have so many different actors
touching things many claims about things
and people are making life-and-death
decisions based upon the stability of
these supply chains
and the fidelity of the information in
them so it turns out that
blockchain technology is actually quite
good for this
because you don't have to trust a
central authority or a trusted third
party or federation of third parties
to make sure that the records are
accurate you can do it in a completely
decentralized way in many cases
identity itself is another example of
that that's one of your most important
assets you have a passport and a
driver's license a birth certificate
a credit score these types of things so
who are you
in statements and claims about your
reputation
this is increasingly linked also with
personally identifiable information so
your data
that facebook and google and other
people mine how do you manage identity
and right now it's given to you by
trusted third parties you're issued a
passport you're issued a driver's
license you're issued
some form of an identity asset through a
private entity or a government entity
and then statements and claims are made
about that identity
again by credit agencies and perhaps
governments with social credit for
example
you don't actually own that and you're
not in control of that
and your identity is managed a lot by
middlemen
in third parties who at any time can
manipulate the records
against your best interest if it's in
their best interest
so the whole point of the blockchain
industry is to take a look at that same
core principle of decentralization
getting rid of middlemen the key word is
disintermediation
and introducing inclusive accountability
to
all of these different topics
so basically the idea is that
you can check that the integrity of the
records in these systems
are as accurate as people assert them to
be
and you know that no one's tampered with
the records they're time stamped they're
immutable they're auditable
and these are super important properties
and there's dozens of others
so like all great experiments bitcoin
basically launched
an entire movement of millions of people
and in just a very short period of time
from
2009 to 2020 we have seen
a global conversation about what makes
good money and our private monies
possible
and then the underlying heart of the
system
inspired many technologists and
entrepreneurs to
launch a new industry called the
blockchain industry
and to start constructing
all kinds of protocols and
cool new ideas to revolutionize the way
that society and commerce works
so in many ways this is one of the most
significant human experiments ever
conducted
because as we enter the 21st century
it's becoming increasingly clear that
globalization is going to fundamentally
change how the entire world
operates we're moving from nation states
or moving from siloed economies
into economies that are deeply
interconnected and
intrinsically transnational and many
ways our laws
how we live how we trade how we think
are as interconnected to the affairs of
other states
as they are to our own backyard
so just the product labels the packaging
what goes into your food could
ultimately be determined by
transnational agreements
by by other people in countries you've
never been
to or met and so given that we live in a
world like that
there's this really hard meta question
to answer
which is who is
in charge
and as we go through the 21st century
it's not really clear
how to answer that question historically
how we've answered that question
is through might might makes right
an empire will form subjugate all others
and then the empire will standardize
everything and then we just follow it by
convention and consensus and then that's
that
but as we move to a global world where
we don't really want to have a world war
and
centralized power around one of the
authority we're trying to manage
for the first time in human history a
way of doing this
without might a way of doing this
through diplomacy and reason
and trade and the problem is that this
is an inexact
science and unfortunately uh the better
angels of our nature
sometimes get consumed by the worst
angels
the worst demons of our nature the
entire point of the blockchain industry
is basically trust regulation
the idea that people have to work
together
who don't really trust each other but
they have to find a way to do so
for a common good to solve a common
problem either to trade
either to preserve the resources and
value that we have
to have sustainability and environmental
policy to solve things like global
pandemics
and unfortunately the old systems that
we have of trust regulation
were through domination and hierarchies
and
the entire point of the blockchain
industry is saying that we can
accomplish trust
regulation by answering this question
who is in charge by saying
no one
you don't need somebody in charge
conceptually
if something as complicated as the world
financial system can run
and alice and bob are able to pay each
other without using an intermediate or a
middleman
and then suddenly you can put things
like democracy and property rights and
fintech and supply chains and identity
into this same type of a structure then
at the end of the day we'll be our own
bank
we're self-sovereign we're in charge of
our own future
and we'll have much better ways of
interacting with the global markets with
the terms and conditions up front
and you'll have immutability and
predictability in the way that the rules
run
there's really no difference in saying
that we'd like our money
to be objective and predictable
from saying we'd like our democracy and
our trade regulation
to be objective and predictable the way
we fund things to be objective and
predictable
so this isn't many reasons why people
are so fanatic about
bitcoin in the blockchain industry
because it isn't really about making
money
it isn't really about building a better
business or making something more
efficient or
making payments a little bit faster if
it was there would certainly be a lot of
people in the industry
but it would just be a job for them this
is more about
answering that fundamental question of
who's in charge of the 21st century
and we're left with one of two answers
either it's going to be a transnational
group of people that
nobody knows much about we didn't pick
and we just have to accept the edicts
and mandates that they've made
just like the totality of human history
there's always been kings and popes and
emperors and rulers that have done so or
we can try something fundamentally
different that's never really
worked before but we get now as a
consequence of technology in the
internet
where we can try to build a world where
no one's in charge
that's what the blockchain industry at
its heart is really about
trust regulation so that we can build
systems where no one is in charge
and those systems have inclusive
accountability meaning we can all verify
that they're working properly not just
the trusted few
they're objective and predictable the
rules apply to everybody the least
amongst us
play by the same rules as the best
amongst us
so the richest and poorest are the same
in that respect
and they spread and propagate by their
edges
not by centralized effort there was no
marketing committee to spread bitcoin
there was no central authority to get
bitcoin mining power to where it's at
it went from just a few computers in
2009 to giant warehouses of miners and
places like mongolia and georgia and so
forth
and it all grew from the bottom up it's
a very different way of thinking about
the world
but in many ways it's a much more
natural way
because ultimately it puts you in charge
so that's what bitcoin is in a nutshell
it was an experiment
the point of the experiment was kind of
two-faced one was
a passion and the other was a
frustration the passion was trying to
solve a very old problem of allowing
people to do business with each other
without middlemen
and the frustration was doing so with
principles
because the principles have been
violated in the past
and the killer app of its is spreading
was trying to create a better form of
money it's certainly debatable what is
good money and it's a
nice conversation to have but the real
value of bitcoin the real experiment
uh leveraged and turned into
an entire industry the blockchain
industry
and that blockchain industry is about
trust regulation
with inclusive accountability so that we
can get to a world where no one's in
charge
except for you for your own life so
that's uh what is bitcoin to me i hope
the
everybody else in the industry has uh
say in this as well and says some cool
stuff about it
uh it really has been the privilege of a
lifetime being in this industry
uh because every day i get to be a
different person
some days i get to be an expert on gov
tech other days i get to think about
medical supply chains other days i get
to think about
what are the nature of privacy and
property rights
some days i get to be a wall street guy
and talk about the bank of the future
but at their heart they're all the same
and that we're just regulating trust
amongst people and
entities that don't really trust each
other for common good
without having to put anybody in charge
using science
cryptography math these things uh
and these systems are global by design
and by default
so thanks for listening i hope this was
helpful and
have a nice day cheers